字幕志愿者 李宗盛
欢迎收看赵华
我是赵华
我是艾伦
大家有没有同甘共苦的感觉
大家还活着吗
大家活过来了吗
还有没有人活着
你今天过得好吗
因为上个礼拜我们是二三录影
是
每天两千点
对
就已经这么不好了
还不知道要讲什么
只能帮大家
给大家就是分析一下状况
其实还有怎么样
但是这个礼拜就好多了
上个礼拜五
对不对
我们没录影就突然谈了3000多点
没错
这个礼拜看起来也是有直吻的迹象
是
而且我们在上个礼拜五之前
利空不断
礼拜五之后利多不断
其实我觉得最微妙的一件事
在上礼拜五之前
你觉得是利多的
他用利空呈现
没错
但是呢
这个礼拜开始
利多就是利多
是的
不一样了
事情变得不一样了
而且是从美国
韩国
台湾都有放送利多的一个情况
而利多会反映
我想就是一个指纹
很重要的条件
没错
不过我们都不用再
不用再打第二只脚吗
有机会
我们都不用再担心了吗
我觉得要担心一下
要担心一下
但是你有讲到一件事
今天我们可能看了
很多叫做供貨下降的趨勢線
還有我們今天會特別講到
流氓光學幫光通送來很大的
送暖
很大的暖暖包
沒錯 這個暖可能有到50度的暖
會燙傷嗎
真的是有燙傷的跡象
好 但是我們先整個來幫他解釋一下
最近的這一個川普
我個人覺得像財報系列
或者說去槓桿系列
或者通膨系列
其實近期都已經有點小尾聲
就是有點利空出鏡
對 講得差不多了嘛
可是川普這一位美國總統
確實利多利空
不斷夾擠股市跟石油市場
這個川普效應還在銳化是不是
其實真的很厲害
他好猛喔
其實我們已經有一陣子
對伊朗戰爭的反應已經淡化掉了
你要打就打 你不打
我們掉以輕心了
對對對 那但是最近
在這個行情比較敏感的時候
川普其實現在講話力道還是非常強勁
不管是利多利空
那他這一個週末有去講
準備對伊朗進行二戰以來最猛烈的攻擊
如果不同意就要斬首
他已經講了好多次
我們要毀滅這個國家
毀滅這個文明我們要斬首
但是到後來就還是基本上乖乖的
就還是坐下來談判
對那不過最近有趣的現象是
川普一直持續釋放好像要停戰的利多
但重點是人家不買單
伊朗說沒有
因為他這個禮拜一
我們凌晨的時候大概四五點的時候有說
我们接着要谈判了
我们要谈判了
然后结果伊朗就直接说
我们目前没有要招待任何人的行程
等一下 这段话
为什么我们是不是重录了
三月讲过
好像有讲过
对 就是这样一直演
然后股市就这么有趣
就是一直反映到现在已经要八月
现在已经八月了
所以非常有趣
五个月来一直反复
没错 你看我这边帮大家总理好了
三月的 四月的 五月的 七月的
七度放話要毀滅一浪
那我們今天錄的12月
搞不好還可以用
所以就先留著
到時候也不用錄了
要省一次錢
不是啦重點是
這件事情為什麼會一直影響股市
主要其實不是影響股市
應該算間接影響
因為它影響的其實是石油價格
石油價格會影響的就是通膨
那通膨現在大家就是最擔心的
尤其可能華許上面以來
有許多新的政策
譬如說它不要有之前的前瞻指引等等
或者說要縮減可能利率決策的次數等等的
所以大家目前來說
對於9月的聯組合理領事決策
可能還是比較緊張一點點
那目前來說
我覺得這件事情
就應該還是會往好方向發展
因為川普他看得出來
比較不想打的應該是他
因為要選舉的是他
一臨到這個股市下修的也是他
是的
然後他也來幫他們美國的一些
石油的企業去降個價吧
降個價吧
那這個是我覺得近期比較重要的新聞
這可能每個禮拜都要幫大家更新一次
不过油价它就像是另类的VIX指标
油价没有再往上跑了
所以市场就往正向发展去了
没错
然后再来另外一个就是韩国在推旧市的措施
是旧市还是害市
基本上就是加速感底的措施
好 但今天看来似乎韩国也顿化了
今天开始走高
今天有拉下引线
什么呢
目前最新的在推动紧急行动权
怎么样紧急
就是把兩倍槓桿的ETF
可在隨著市場波動的時候
調到1.5倍或者是1倍
買線股
去槓桿是這樣去的啊
就是他們有一個比較
譬如說可能又暫停交易了
跌7%
那就直接降槓桿
其實這個邏輯我覺得有點奇怪
因為感覺有點
我降槓桿
如果反彈的時候
我是不是也只用1.5倍在彈
但是我是用2倍再跌
你是跌到一定程度
才會跌1.5倍嘛
那你反彈回來
是不是用1.5倍再彈
是
我不確定啦
他可能不是這樣理解
但我目前是這樣理解
不要發了好不好
以後對搞不清楚的商品
不要再發了
南韓人
沒錯
像那個大小魔都有出來講
他們這個南韓的去槓桿
應該已經接近尾聲了
對 所以我覺得
接下來應該還是會有一些
這個底部反彈的機會
那另外一個記憶體呢
漲價循環未完
這些數字都非常好
重點是今天來亞可以公布了
哇 那個
月增50%
我看那個柱狀體
他們前面已經每年增百%幾百%了
那個柱狀體還是前面那個
幾百%柱狀體的一倍以上
年增720%
對對對
月增50%
對
我比我上個月多拿50%
重點是上個月已經是歷史新高了
然後還特別又再出一根
所以記憶體循環確實
我們韓國股市這幾天
這邊好不容易組了一個底部
然後這兩根在殺破底之後
這幾天大概五天的時間
又沒有再破底了
這邊有沒有機會來個足個底
先把月線站回來再去挑戰季線
我覺得是可以稍微關注一下的
好 加油
然後另外一個就是我們台灣
台灣我們經歷了轟轟烈烈的
這個華新科事件
中探偵事件
信倉電事件
沒有錯 這個呢
因為不只是一直漲停會被禁儲置
你一直跌停也會禁儲置
這幾天還有那種儲置已經都賣不掉了
還延長儲置
没错 这个看来是有伤到蛮多人的筋骨
是的 因为我特别去看一下华星科
我特别去看了一下那个中探针
其实在上个礼拜大概有
大概还有三到四天都是跌停板
对 那个发生什么事情
那个融资几万张
然后几万张很多维持率都已经一百零几%了
可是断头也卖不掉
卖不掉啊 因为你每天就是成交量就一百七八十张
你那几万张那排队根本就卖不到
所以你被破断头你也断不掉
你只能一直被灌在里面
那因为这一些关系之后呢
所以目前證交所快速的去
实施了一个新的规则
帮大家快速的捋清楚
首先一般的处置是从10天变5天
当冲过高的处置从12天会变7天
基本上不超过一个礼拜
另外的 戳合的速度加快了
不管之前是5分钟的
还是你被第二次处置到20分钟的
全部都调整2分钟
那再来放宽千金股的标准
1000块以上的
如果你连续6个交易日
达到300元以上的价差
就使用30%
那之後每上升一個區間
譬如說1000到2000是這樣
那大概2001到3000
就直接加150塊
對 就變成450
當然這個他們可能千金股以上
他們還要再去調整
因為我們還有萬元股
沒錯 對
那目前來說就是每一個級別
都是以這個基準值
向上加150塊
不然高價股被關
連8顆被關
對啊 8顆還要被關
對不對
那也就是說
基本上呢
接下来整个撮合的速度
跟时间处置的时间都会变短
那同时呢帮大家补充一下
8月10号上路哦
是溯及既往的
对 比如说你可能
比如我举例啦
随便举例个
比如说华欣科
比如说他可能要处置20分钟10天
但是呢现在变5天
那如果我礼拜二进去
礼拜8月10号就可以出来了
所以都是溯及既往的
那也就是说
下礼拜8月
下礼拜8月1
8月10号礼拜一
应该会有一堆个股都放出来
抽到监狱卡之後又抽到特赦卡
沒錯沒錯
就應該下週一很多都不需要儲置
那剩下的新儲置就會維持這個遊戲規則
那我覺得至少這應該可以增加流動性
那你覺得總體來說有沒有需要加強的先生
我覺得乾脆就不要儲置
啊啊啊啊啊啊
乾脆就不要儲置嗎
就直接五分鐘暫停交易
就可能當初那一個波動過大的時候
因為我覺得儲置你漲停的時候
大家都沒意見啦
不過我們本來就有波動過大的時候會緩搓
對啊對啊對啊
本來就有啊 其實已經是制度了啦
所以我覺得處置這個制度
我不太曉得為什麼
一定要存在 對
當然它可能有它的用因
這個我們就相信
相信金管會 好
那最後跟大家講一下
這個目前盤勢的狀況
怎麼樣 穩了嗎 還沒
還沒啊 上跪偏穩
上市還差一點
怎麼會 我以為相反
你看我們這幾天都是沿著
月線跟下降趨勢線
沒錯 對
今天呢 其實盤中有站上月線
但收盤價沒有
今天收盤價是有被灌到大概12點多一點
然後尾盤又拉起來
可是不管有沒有呢
基本上下降趨勢線是沒有被破壞的
可是呢 在整個融資的結構跟剛剛講到那些利多
然後在整個亞馬遜有創高的CSP
我覺得科技股短線應該利空出境的狀態之下
我覺得這個位置上有機會做突破
即便沒有突破
沒有突破 下來打第二隻腳
我個人覺得這邊回到前滴附近
應該也是要勇敢接的位置
好 在貴買呢
貴買最近的走勢都比較強
免殺紅
對 因為CPO啊
然後這個探針系列的
都是貴買的全資股
復活了
對 全部復活
真的復活系晶圓啊
沒錯 聯亞 環球晶
今天也都漲停
所以你可以發現這三根
就表現除了輸第一根之外
後面兩根都有贏
所以資金往中小型去做移動
那一口气呢也跌破了下降趋势线
对 所以接下来大盘
桂买要挑战的是这个平台的位置
这个平台的位置呢
大概一个区间
但你抓一个整数就好
400站上就对了
所以呢后面要挑战压力区
看能不能站上来
突破当然最好
那不过下来的话
我们看有没有机会拉一个N字形
再继续去垫高
所以桂买呢
这个空方的下降的这个轨道
已经结束了
那接下来看这边要主体
还是要B上去
先有一些更安心的状态
再来一个涨多回落
等重新上车的机会
所以我觉得都还OK啦
没想到贵满也是集谈三天之后
竟然把这个下降压力线给过了
这边的话是大型股
我想台积电这两天
是有把空间让出来的
这也就是贵满
对一方面让出来
一方面可能ENIB也对它造成了一些
短线的利空
没关系它不怕听到烂掉
所以台积电目前来说
这一根涨停板上礼拜五
但现在在补这个缺口
所以在回补缺口的过程中
亮缩我觉得是好事
但記得回來補完缺口
敢買要買
對 那目前來說台積電這兩天都跌
大概跌5%啦
這兩天時間大概跌5%
但是其他周邊的中小型資金
反而溢出是非常強勁的
另外發哥在昨天漲停
今天盤中有站回季線
那收盤價沒有比較可惜
但空方趨勢也結束了
然後這裡的小錢高收盤價沒過比較可惜所以我覺得後面看後面能不能去电高一下因为发哥今天的量有点大这边套牢的这边套牢或者这边套牢的
都应该在这个时候去做一些调节
那或者是说有人底部买上来
这里有做互利调节
所以我觉得发哥再看一下
这几天这个大量高点
今天高点能够做突破
我觉得趋势应该会更强
对不然的话
下来也是看一下
有没有机会拉一个N字形出来
这个是发哥的部分
其实上礼拜五
如果美股是亚马逊财报
台股就是发哥的发说会跟财报
因为发哥
他其实跟去年比获利是下降的
但对年底所谓的AIA ASIC
他是给予乐观展望
所以就直接送他两根掌停板
我觉得那个就是利多利空情绪的一刀切
所以广告回来的话
我们要先讲有一个族群了
这个族群很奇妙
我们在讲的时候
其实关注度非常高
就是CPU
可是他在跌的时候你也说
就2028才要用
現在獲利大航都還沒有上來
但流民光學給了我們一個
很大的暖暖包
他跟一家公司叫ATX
簽了一個長約
告訴大家
光通訊未來會非常缺
比記憶體還要缺
好 來吧
我們來看一下
我講CPU之前
先跟大家講一下
因為Q2接Q3了嘛
然後我們祭底的時候這個大修正
那現在是重新的這個大家在懷疑跟恐懼跟希望中的時候呢
通常未來都會有新的主流族群出來
所以大家後續可以關注的是Q2沒在漲的
或者Q2殺爛的
那其中一個就是CPU
再來另外一個就是散熱
再來第三個就是PCB的上中油
什麼富橋啊
那一群其實最近表現不會輸CPO
好 因為是7月很多股票可能是大跌
可是有的人是6月底之前
就已經跌過了 或者是沒動
對 其實還有一個記憶體模組廠
我覺得也可以稍微關注一下
因為也沒動 對
那沒關係 那個後續我們再要再講
我們今天先講的就是近期
這個延續性很好
然後這個題材性又非常不錯的
就是CPO
那這個流氓光學有預告
這個要缺爆
鲁麟成 刺井呢
整個的關鍵材料就是所謂零化音
這個嚴重的程度呢
可能比記憶體還要短缺
不過我對這句話我有點好奇
他說缺關鍵材料
那對於需要關鍵材料的
光通訊廠商不就變利空了嗎
不是因為他們沒有訂單
是上面出不來嘛
那你這個就是
就跟PCB 磁波纖部漲價一樣
對啊 那你載板類
等於整體產業其實需求很旺
對對對對
所以我覺得這個應該會是一個
整体产业链最上有的利多
那再来呢
他们说目前的缺货量
出货量还是少30%
所以这个缺口可能还会大于30%
未来
那另外零化音是什么
其实就是一个三五族的化合物半导体
然后是制作光通讯元件的材料
那目前来说
细光子是没有办法有效发光的
所以要零化音作为雷射基板
那即便呢
你要架构转为相关的CPU
只是改变雷射器的位置
它这个零化音的依赖呢
还是非常大的
那再来另外一个呢
零化硬目前整个的供给
有大概六成到七成是来自于中国
所以在美中关系的
跟中国有对限制出口的状态之下
确实是相对紧缺
那另外一个除了供给紧缺之外呢
需求呢原本也从改为单位
改成益为单位
这个也跳太多了吧
要加几个零啊
对所以呢
这个就会是一个非常大的一个题材
那其实已经炒很久了
在Q1估值整个拉起来之后
其实Q2的后面两个月
其实就是大幅度修正
跟被动员接有点像
只是时间跟幅度不太一样
另外呢
这个是相关的一些
那个什么
供应链 产业链
原料 机板 外影片 光芯片
对 光模组
还有这个CPU的交换机
这个是成品了
好 那我们就来看一下
这个台湾股市的
先跟大家讲一下
这个流氓光学还有AAOI
AOI 8月6號要公布財報
那整個的目前像AXT
AXT
最近表現也很兇
30幾塊跑到70塊
大概3 4天的時間
AXT就是零化音相關的
最受惠的
那台灣呢
我們就來看一下
這邊以原物料來講
就是零化音比較直接的
大概是前面這幾家
就是三五族的
聯亞是龍頭
最近全新比較強
以前是穩帽比较强
但穩帽最近比较弱一点点
重见
对对对
然后IET跟环宇KY这两个呢
比较不常去看
为什么因为容易禁处置
那三不五时环宇KY怎么又发现禁处置
所以处置这个制度
看后面对环宇KY股价会不会
比较有好的反应
不过处置股常常铸长铸跌
是的
那现在至少不铸跌了
对OK
那另外一个呢就相关的
就是我们的光通讯厂
光盛波罗威上全华新光还有联军
像联军可能是做封测场
那今天的表现呢
基本上快清一色都涨停板
而且像上拳啊
像联军啊
其实还拉尾盘
原本盘中是
4 5% 3 4%
尾盘有拉起来
那不过呢
像这种反应是最直接的
这个很早就都涨停板了啦
对 所以我觉得
以现在来讲的话
这个可以称为T0
这个最直接的
然后这一排呢就T1
好的
对 然后封测场呢
比较会变在T2
因为封测场通常都是反应最慢
对
有一陣子他們都沒漲
聯軍自己創新高
可是這個已經是漲完再回落了
所以這邊我覺得都可以稍微注意一下
聯軍至少不用怕缺料
他幫人家封了
沒錯 而且只要那邊好
聯軍一定好 因為做封測
那我們來看一下第一個就全新
原本想講聯亞 聯亞比較貴
那我們講比較親民的 全新
在前一陣子也是有接近500塊的價格
後面這一段行情
其實我只是沒有拉很遠
前面已經震盪一陣子了
一路走回落 回落 回落
回落到这几天呢
在前一阵子上上礼拜的时候
先拉了一段行情
站回了下降趋势线
这个地方
所以今天看下降趋势线突破
没错
它已经早早就突破过了
它突破过
但是它又回落测一次
对 转盘整
所以我觉得这个是好的地方
因为它第一个这个地方没破底
没破底之后呢
又站回了月线
那今天又涨停嘛
那涨停的过程中
只要这个高点做突破
刚好也跟季线位置差不多
这里就会是一个WD
所以我觉得大家不用说
两根了20% 30%了
那后面再买会不会是有点追的样子
其实我觉得
因为你反映一个底部
它一定要有几根K棒去做
所以你必须牺牲那个涨幅
那你也不用说明天就一定要进场
你只要确立它能够打W底
然后拉一段这边走回侧
那这边会成为支撑
如果真的回侧到这里
这里就会是一个好的买点
所以我觉得全新目前来说
还在一个主底的过程
那这个主底希望可以有一个漂亮的底部
然后对未来的股价
至少也可以有机会先去挑战前高
那前高447嘛
今天收盘至少还有100多块
所以我觉得是可以稍微关注一下的
好再来另外一个呢就是上全
那上全呢其实
这个族群大概就是什么波罗威华新光啊
上全光盛这一个大族群嘛
那波罗威跟华新光比较容易进处置
上全之前很容易进处置
但营收慢慢跟上之后就
比较没有容易进处置了
然后筹码目前来说也还不错
前面是破底的
破底拉回來也才剛佔回
代量佔回月仙而已
所以位階很低
這邊我會覺得先挑戰這兩個大量的高點
然後這裡是個壓力區
所以上去的時候先看能不能做突破
突破佔回來有回落
再來去找買點就好了
因為目前來說其實它的型態也偏空
就是導溫型
對 它雖然感覺上想要嘗試打底
可是一次年限破掉 再破掉
沒錯 不好看耶
其實撐不住
對 它撐不住
其實整個CPU基本上都長這副德性
沒有 他特別弱保 沒有嗎
沒有 波羅威也是前面破底
華星光也是破底 光晟也破底
對對對
所以這幾天其實大家不用覺得
所以全新長得還不錯
全新算強 沒破底
所以這一陣子大家不用覺得
CPU沒做到很可惜 沒有沒有沒有
這個是阻底而已
對 所以現在位階很低
至少我們知道未來要出貨
然後未來又原物料緊缺
對 所以他們長線的基本面題材是在的
那只不過技術面上
目前正在努力的打出一個好底部
另外一個呢就是聯軍
然後聯軍也破底
對 聯軍
他也破底 好的
聯軍今天反彈呢
但是呢
他下降趨勢現在還沒做突破
還沒有站上啊
是的
那不過今天帶量有在努力啦
所以我覺得稍微再關注一下
因為基本面其實也是紮實的
那等這個下降趨勢做突破
再來去看有沒有機會阻底
那個時候再介入就好
因為這幾天都在放量
那放量過程中我覺得都是好事
只是要等形态更进一步好转
当然如果你说我想摆长线
那我觉得分批买在这个位置上
已经算便宜的
也可以稍微关注一下
以上就是帮大家稍微整理一下
这三档股票
好
所以今天呢
一样如果需要我们节目所有的图卡资料
包括等一下我们的大来宾
也整理了很多关于ETF的图表资料
都欢迎到我们赵华艾伦说的YouTube频道
我们会放在首页的听闻栏里面
免费提供给大家
之前的节目的也都在里面
那刚刚讲到的光通讯
因为之前下跌
没有一个产业大佬出来讲
那现在刘明出来讲了
我们似乎可以比较放心
但如果对个股的波动
十分的害怕的话
下一段节目就要来全面解析了
到底是要买主被动式的ETF
还是有其他更好的选择
现在正式检视你ETF布局的好时机
欢迎回来赵老华
爱人说
爱人有没有发现一件事情
就是我们的资产
跟我们的体重的管理
就根本就是两件事
完全是相反的概念
对
变胖很容易
减肥
很难
要瘦一点点都很难
资产要增加
很难
要变快
要变瘦
瘦很多
很容易
两三天
对
没有两三个礼拜
两三个礼拜
怎么会这样呢
我们今天的来宾呢
他也是要告诉我们说
之前他有一段时间
也是很努力的受伸
最近有这样的感触
不过如果我们在体重管理上
我们没有办法管理得很好
我们资产管理上
应该可以管理得好一点吧
好的
这一波跌下来
可能大家对于买个股
真的会有点余悸悚
可是我们会发现
在上个礼拜五大反弹的时候
外资在干嘛
在干嘛
外资大买
我們台股ETF
那一前十名全部都是
主動式的啊 被動式的啊
所以連外資想要抄底
或者是想要撿平
都買台股ETF
所以因為他們可能也不知道要買什麼
那我直接買ETF
那這個就要來請教裡面的秘辛
就是我們的
ETF交付 谷魚
哇 OK
好 那個各位觀眾朋友大家好
我是谷魚
這幾天我們的資產稍微有負胖
因為反彈啦
對對對對 沒有錯
可是呢
我們在這一波反彈的過程裡面
事實上有觀察到
很多很有趣的一個現象
所以我想我們今天就花一點時間
來跟我們的投資朋友做一些分享
好 今天請我們的谷魚來
在講說上禮拜五
這個外資也在大買我們的ETF
以及我們現在叫做
股災過後
我們重建家園
如何用ETF
我們能再相信這些
主動式的經理人嗎
當然可以相信
因為我們從
績效的角度上面來看
他能夠為投資人創造超額報酬的機會
基本上還是比較高的
你不能夠因為呢
他一兩次的一個下跌就去否決了他相關的一個表現所以我們首先先來看一下讓投資人感覺到很痛苦的應該是7月的這一波
它基本上它是從高點
一路往下修正
那中間有一度
加權指數的話
甚至跌破了四字頭
我們看到了399的
這樣的一個數字
哇 不得了啊
很多人在7月初的時候
還在跟我講什麼
還跟我講說
老師
7月就見5萬了
結果沒有想到
5沒有看到
卻看到了3
這個落差有點大
大家有點難過
所以你看
在最近的整體的
一個月的一個報酬率表現來看
事實上呢
反倒是這種高席型的
它的表現是比較抗跌的
其實也符合我們的預期
我們之前在談投資的時候就有講過
你如果今天遇到市場反彈的時候
應該說市場在回檔的時候
那像這種高期型的產品
因為有現金鼓勵的關係
它相對是比較抗跌的
可是主動式的一個產品
剛好是一個邏輯顛倒的概念
我今天上漲的時候我追求破洞
所以它的績效衝很快
可是當回檔這個時間上面來看的話
我們以被動式的市值型跟主動式
來做一個比較
你會發現這個修正的幅度也相當的
一個快
所以這就是我們在
投資的過程當中
投資朋友必須要去做選擇的
你今天追求的是績效
還是你追求的是穩定
如果穩定的話呢
高席型相對來講穩定
可是呢你要追求績效
而且追的比大盤還要多
那我想主動式的產品
還是比較好的一個選擇
那當然很多人會講說
老師不對啊
可是7月份跌了這麼多
它真的是比較好的一個選擇嗎
老師不對啊
我要穩定的高報酬
穩定的高報酬嗎
穩定的高報酬
以前我們就討論過這個議題了嘛
那你要做長期持有啊
你不覺得我很堅持這件事情嗎
認識他多久就講多久
對 你的堅持也是我那個
努力的一個目標嘛 對不對
但是我們後來發現了一件事情
你要嘛就是配置要做得好
你要嘛就是你的投資的時間拉得夠長
你才有辦法得到所謂的穩定的高報酬
但是我們在7月下跌之後
我們再回過頭來看
整體市場的一個表現
其實你還是會發現到一件事情
主動式的產品
它在整體的一個報酬表現上面
它還是比我們家權報酬指數
來賺的更多一點
所以7月雖然揮檔了
可是整體整個年度
它還是比較好的一個狀態
當然裡面的話
已經發行超過一年的產品
目前有五檔
只有一檔
它是落後於家權指數的
可是我覺得
我們不能夠這樣子去評價它
因為那一檔的話
它追求的是高息
高息
要的是比較穩定的息
對 所以我們從
這些產品它當初設定的目標來看
從00980A一直到00985A
這些產品裡面
其實大部分都是以追求
超越加權指數為目標的
那它有沒有達到他們當初所講的
事實上是有的
所以我是覺得像
不要因為一兩次的一個回檔
你就去否決了這個產品相對的一個表現
我覺得這樣子是
有點看的太短了一點
時間放長你會發現
其實他的績效還是蠻不錯的
也等於是這一年來對不對
應該是第一次遇到這麼大幅的回檔
也是一次的考驗
然後我們在這一次就發現了
不只外資在買他們
他們自己的經理人
也是有各種不同的招式來應對股災
對
而且這個招式的話你會發現
原來在不同的時間點
經理人的做法
真的是完全通通都不一樣的
那我們這邊的話
我幫各位做了一個很有趣的整理
我們幫各位整理了00980A
00981A跟00985A
這三檔在市場上
它相對來講規模跟知名度比較高的
主動式的ETF
我們來看一下
在這一次回檔的過程
大概是從7月的27號
一直到7月31號
這段時間
他們到底都在幹什麼
而且你會發現啊
風格完全都不一樣喔
那我們先來看一下呢
我們的981A
規模第一大的
規模第一大
那你有沒有發現
在下跌週期的前三天啊
他大致上都沒有什麼反應
沒有反應
他沒有什麼太大的反應
他只有因為說呢
在下跌的過程中
可能投資人有一些贖回的動作
那他有把手中的持股
我們做了一些小幅度的調整
但是請你幫我注意喔
趙華我問你
我們這一波
7月有一天漲了3000點
是哪一天
上禮拜五啊
上禮拜五嘛對不對
上禮拜五的話呢
請幫我記住這個日子喔
7月31號
是喔 是
關鍵日嘛
那我們來看一下
我們剛剛講說什麼
981A下跌第一天沒有反應
下跌第二天沒有反應
下跌第三天
沒有反應
可是
可是重點來了
31號上漲3000點嘛 對不對
他在7月30號大買
17秒
不是
這也太神了吧
為什麼
他在反彈的前一天
大幅度的去做加碼的動作
神不神
這代表經理人他在抓這個市場的
轉折的時間點
他抓得非常的精準
而且中間這段過程裡面
不管市場出現任何的一個雜音
甚至懷疑他的一個判斷
他都不為所動
他就穩穩的幫投資人抓到了
7月30到7月31
這一波超大的反彈
因為這一天的話
台股就是你剛剛講到
我們看到三字頭
沒錯
所有人應該是很悲觀的一天
他在大家悲觀的那一天
進場大賣
而且隔天的話
再繼續做加碼的一個動作
大漲日還加碼
對 大漲日再繼續加碼
重點是他還買得到
對 他還買得到
他還買得到
所以你有沒有發現
以0098EA的這個操盤的風格
上面來看的話
他等同就是說
今天被他逮到一個反彈的機會
勇敢抄底
然後後面再上漲的話
他繼續做追漲的一個動作
他做兩件事
一個當然就是國際
跌到他的平均成本加碼的時候
他選擇加碼
絲毫沒有要退讓
再來是他買了大台的台紙期
對
欸
對 他大台台紙期的部分
買的部位還不小
對 因為我們一般來講
像主動式的ETF
他單一成分股的上限
大概就是控制在10%
那這一次00981A
為什麼我們會說他大台買的不少
因為他一口氣
就買了將近6%的一個部位
然後他占他的整體的成分股的排名
瞬間占到第四名
這個我們在過去看
00981A的一個操板上面來講
這是一個很少見的現象
以前他也會買
可是他可能就只買一點點
1% 2%
然後放在後面
可能有點類似在調控那種感覺
這一次不是
他是直接就大買的
所以很多
投資朋友都在思考這個問題
如果主動式的經理人
他去買了8月的一口
8月的那個大台
買那麼大的一個部位
是不是代表他覺得
8月的這個走勢的話呢
也可能會有一段不錯的一個行情
才會這樣子去做重壓的一個動作
市場上有很多的討論
也有人說因為外資買了很多的981A
所以他自己也要做一些抗衡這樣子
對 沒有錯
當然有很多的一個討論
但是基本上呢
你如果今天手持期貨的多單
我們就會認為說呢
你對於他後市的行情
才是比較看好的
是積極的
對對對
所以這是我們在看到981A
在這一波下跌跟反彈的過程中
他操作的一個手法
那我們接下來來看的話呢是另外一檔
那另外一檔的話呢是那個980A
這檔是野村的經理人
那野村的經理人的話呢
我們也發現一個很有趣的現象
我在想說啊
這兩個人是不是失出頭門啊
為什麼
你知道為什麼嗎
等他查一下
你看喔第一天沒有買
第二天沒有買
第三天還是沒有買
有一隻恐龍
對 都不會動
都不會動
不管市場發生什麼事情
搓他踢他打他他都不會動
可是呢
他竟然跟00981A
幹了一件完全相同的事情
到底為什麼
他在7月30號這一天
大買
30號大買
然後呢一樣隔天大漲之後
再繼續大買
你有沒有覺得他們兩個的操盤手法
幾乎完全是一模一樣的
也就是說在下跌的過程中
他都沒有太多的一個動作
可是呢 當他發現市場情緒被擠壓到某個瞬間點
有機會出現反彈
他就立刻毫不猶豫的進行加碼的一個動作
那你那天在幹嘛
我那天在幹嘛嘛
我那天等著要加碼
然後呢
但是沒有想到他反彈
什麼啦
所以人家主動嘛
那我們都被動
我們沒有做到這麼主動
因為畢竟資金有限
是啊 也對
他們的部位比較大
對 我們會比較想要說
我在有限的資金裡面
盡可能做到我認為最好的那一個點
但是沒有想到反彈如此的快速
他們資金部位大
他們也可以分批加碼
為什麼不
分批加碼嘛
這個就涉及到操盤的手法完全不一樣
所以我們看到981A跟980A
他們都是抄底加碼
這樣子的操盤風格
可是我們來看一下
另外一檔
985A完全顛倒
這就跟趙華想的就很像
985A下跌的第一天加碼
下跌的第二天加碼
下跌的第三天他再繼續加碼
有錢就該這樣花不算
有錢就該這樣子花
往下下跌的過程我攤平
本多必勝對不對
可是大漲的前一天
一漲都不買
買好了啊
他前面就買好了
隔天大漲的時候
他還是沒有做任何的一個買進
所以你有沒有發現
其實經理人操盤的手法差異很大
有些人想辦法去搞抄底的動作
有些人的話呢就是在
下跌的過程中我就開始買
等你真的反彈上去的時候
我前面的部位已經建好了
所以呢我就在那邊等你幫我做抬轎的一個動作
所以你會發現啊像主動式
的這些操盤的一個手法
它呢可以讓投資朋友好好的花時間來研究
甚至呢你可以去思考一個問題
哪個經理人操盤的手法
跟你想要的是比較接近的
因為我們常在講說啊
主動是ETF的投資
就等同是你把你的資金交給一個經理人
幫你做操盤
那你跟他心靈要契合啊
對不對
他比如說他買的這些標的是你喜歡的
他操盤的手法是你喜歡的
那你把他找出來之後
你就把資金交給他
那你在投資的過程中
你的那個情緒就會比較穩定
可是我剛剛想的有點相反
我想說如果我是A類型的
我是不是應該買B類型的經理人
他可以跟我互補
例如說我不可能再那麼積極的買大台
對 我可能就比較像985分批分批分批
對啊 那我乾脆就
那你就去買981A嗎
對啊 出去做一個平衡
這樣子講也是我
對啊 因為他做到我做不到的事
反正你自己也會買個股嘛
對啊 所以其實你在
做這種主動式ETF投資的過程裡面
其實我真的會跟投資朋友說一個建議
你好好的去研究他的一個手法
再來去思考說
我是要買跟我的性格相近的還是我要找一個互補的經理人那這樣子的話你在投資的過程中你有沒有覺得好像又多了一些很莫名其妙的樂趣就跑出來了
但是剛剛有提到
即使從年初算到現在主動是還是銀市值
對不對
BOT
就是這個BOT
很多人就是四五月才去買
所以呢
七元一回土
哎唷
不但沒有賺
搞不好還倒賠
對
所以如果手上現在ETF是呈現
因為之前累積的部位是在比較高檔區的
我現在就可以加碼了嗎
當然啊
當然可以加碼
那你為什麼那天不買
你有錢就加碼
對不對
但是我們在這個部分
我覺得有一個前提是
投資朋友一定要先弄清楚的
ETF你跑來問我
我一定都跟你講可以加碼
但是但是你不能夠只聽我講前面
我後面那一段你也得聽清楚
就是說我們在看加碼這件事情
這件事情它有個前提
就是你要先看它的股價的趨勢
有些產品它是往右上走的
有些產品的話它是平盤
甚至它是往下走的
那我們今天在講說
如果今天遇到市場的回檔
你問我它可不可以做加碼
你選的是那種時間拉長
它會往右上角走的
這個不要怕
你就是有閒錢做加碼的動作
那時間拉的夠長
就算現在回檔了
之後他還是有機會
可以超過你現在的投入成本
可是呢,如果今天他是像這種
平盤甚至一路往下的
這個
我們就不要談什麼加碼了
好不好,這種你可能
花了很多時間在上面
結果最後會繞得一無所獲
像這種的話就比較不太適合去做加碼
當然除了
選對產品之外
還有一件事情更重要
你要有錢啊
嘿嘿嘿
這是一個很實際的問題
對
譬如說你看喔
我們現在在講說
7月這麼大的一個回檔
那真的有很多人衝進去做加碼的動作嗎?
可能沒有幾個喔
那這些人不是說他沒有掌握到反彈的機會
而是他有掌握到了
但是沒錢
這是一個很大的問題
因為5月6月一直漲嘛
就大家就想說
5月6月一直漲的話
我還把錢留在我手上幹什麼
當然是ALL IN全部都投進去嘛
結果呢 7月開始回檔之後的話呢
他反而沒有子彈可以打了
所以呢就錯過了一個反彈的一個機會
所以我們常在講說
能不能夠加碼取決兩件事情
第一個
你的產品有沒有長期去漲
這是第一個條件
第二個條件的話呢
有沒有錢啊
你如果前面子彈打太快的話呢
真的這個反彈的機會出現的時候
你是沒有能力去做加碼的一個動作的
不過如果以長期區長這件事情的話
是執行
對不對 台股是執行
是長期區長
然後如果是比較綜合的科技型
甚至現在跟所謂的AI或半導體相關的
應該也是長期區長
我覺得這樣範圍就還蠻清晰的
對對對對
那你如果呢
那個範圍沒有辦法自己找的話
沒有 那很簡單
就我剛剛講的
你那個Google五年點下去
你就看那個圖是不是往右上角走
如果是的話
那你要去做加碼
相對來會比較容易一點
可是一旦涉及到加碼這個議題
投資朋友都是貪心的
他不太可能說看到一點點回蕩
就想要去做加碼的動作
那你不是說你自己也是
對
你不是說你要等最好的那個點
你太熟了的圖
不然吐詞
愛倫聽不下去
可是每個人都一樣啊
對不對
我如果今天預期
它還有更低的一個價位出現
或是我有預期
可能會在
哪個價位出現支撐的話
那我一定會想辦法等到支撐出現
再去做買進的動作
因為我這個人投資的風格是這個樣子
買到
是我賺到
如果沒有買到
就代表這個價位與我無緣
我們這是抱持著這種心情在投資的
佛系佛系
對 我們是佛系投資的
講緣分
可是呢
我們還是要跟投資朋友講一下
到底呢 我們在做這種
短線回檔的過程當中
我們會觀察哪一些指標來決定
我要不要來做投入的一個動作
那當然我們會用的是那個
最近比較有爭議的一個指標
比較有爭議的指標
對 因為這個所謂的有爭議的話
主要是
券商的算法
資料庫的算法
還有官方的算法
完全都長得不一樣
其實以前是大家都差不多的
可是因為後來
那個融資券的比例提高了
還有ETF的投資
其實趙華這問你就知道
我們早期做ETF之後
根本沒有人理我們
對不對
也不至於啦
對 但是從那個高息ETF出來
他AI風潮之後
這個商品就變得哇
變地開花
對對對
可是呢
在更早之前的話
事實上ETF他占的規模
比較沒有這麼大
大家喜歡個股
大家還是比較喜歡個股
所以呢那時候
縱使有很多不同的算法
但是其實算出來的數字沒有差很多
可是現在 ETF 的規模變大了
當充龍資銅券的量也變大了之後
那你用整戶維持率的算法
個股含 ETF 的算法
跟只算個股的算法
你現在會得到三個截然不同的一個結果
是
所以呢我們在
同一個時間上面來講
假設我們以
7月30號的那一天來看
7月30號那天是個很有趣的日子
7月30號那天的話
各位可以幫我看一下
這個的話是不含ETF的維持率
在7月30號那天
它的維持率只剩下131%的一個位置
可是你如果看券商的
券商的維持率的話大概是155%
可是你如果看整戶的
大概有171%
就能夠發現這個數字差很多
可是我們投資看的是哪一個
我們投資看的是這個
只算個股的這個維持率
因為我們重點是在於
個股現在到底承受了多大的壓力
是不是呢
有機會馬上遇到斷頭
被券長去做一個處理
所以呢我們以前在看這個數字的時候
只要發現
它一旦跌破135%以下
市場就容易出現恐慌
那甚至呢
之後的話會出現板彈的一個現象
其實投資朋友可以去思考一下
當我的融資維持率低於140的時候
市場在幹嘛
市場說
斷頭潮要出現了
然後很多人開始出現融資追繳的
一些相關的壓力
其實我們過去的投資都有個概念
一旦追繳的壓力
撐過去之後
後面市場很容易迎來反彈
而那個數字的話
我幫各位整理在這個地方
大概你落到135到115這個區間
市場就會開始
出現反彈的一個動作
那其實我必須跟我們的觀眾朋友
坦白一件事情
我其實是在等破130
好 但是你看喔
因為這個晚上才出來
也等於是7月29號
等於7月30號做動作
是因為看到29號那個數字
沒錯
所以破135的時候
經理人開始有動作
對 是真的
對對對
所以經理人的話呢
他基本上可能也有在參考這個數字
只是說他因為資金比較雄貨
所以他提前去做布局的一個動作
因為晚上看到他隔天做動作很合理
對不對
29號晚上看到30號白天做處理
對對對
那我們的話是希望有機會
可以再更低一點
對但是就是比較遺憾沒有等到
不過我們還是可以把
我們在看這個數字的一些習慣
以及在哪個時間點
它有可能會出現反彈
我幫各位做一個整理
讓我們的投資朋友
如果以後還有機會
去看這個數字的話
也可以來做一個參考
歷史真的叫做不斷重演
對沒錯
這次也是類似的
好,所以如果說現在叫災後重建
也雖然反彈了三天
但是也離高點還有一段距離
尤其是一個股
或是說像剛剛講的主動式ETF
跌得比較深
所以現階段重新來佈局我們的ETF
你的參考跟建議
我想我們還是要跟投資朋友去強調一件事情
你的核心配置
你一定要想清楚
它到底是什麼
那我們過去在談核心配置
我們講的都是同一件事情
被動式的市值型
它才是你真正的核心的配置
其實我們在前面的資料裡面就有看過了
你今天市場一旦在回檔的過程當中
其實主動是因為它追求超額報酬
所以它在回檔的過程中
它的速度也會比較快
那很多人在做投資的時候
我們常常在講說
痛苦是比較出來的
我今天大盤跌10%
結果我的主動是跌了17%
那你一定會對主動是非常的不滿
所以我們在看這個東西的時候的話呢
請你幫我記住
核心的
你可以至少佔50%以上
然後你可以盡可能去買這些
被動式式執行的一個產品
先把你對市場的基本部位
先拿下來
之後的話呢
剩餘的錢才去買這一些
有機會拿到超額報酬的
譬如說什麼產業型啊
主動型啊
主題型啊這一些
它比較適合去追更多的一個
超額報酬的表現
所以其實投資的概念是這個樣子
先求穩
該拿的我先把它拿起來
然後之後我再來追求我所謂的超額報酬
這個在投資的順序裡面千萬不要顛倒了
你顛倒的話你再看市場就會比較難過一點
所以我們在這邊也幫各位把
常見的市值型、高級型跟主動式的這些產品
我們把它的一個Beta的係數
它的一個波動率
我都幫你整理在這個地方
那投資朋友就可以去思考
我今天在7月的時候
你對市場的感覺是什麼
是一般痛苦還是極度的痛苦
如果你是感到極度的痛苦
那就代表你的波動太高了
這時候就可以考慮
把你的這些主動式的產品
稍微把它的部位降低一點
你可以把它放到這種高股息的產品裡面去
那這樣子的話呢
可以去平衡你整個部位的一個波動
其實啊
你今年以來啊
不管你投資式執行、高席型
還有那個主動式的產品
其實你整年的報酬率
應該都有機會可以拿到40%以上
它落差沒有你想像中這麼的大
可是呢你在回檔過程當中
你的感覺是差很多的
所以呢這次呢我們在這邊
幫投資朋友呢
把這張表整理出來之後
讓投資朋友可以回去去思考一下
到底怎樣的配置才是比較適合你的投資邏輯
因為我們也有聽到身邊的朋友在討論
去年到現在買高鞋啊
一開始就覺得好像傻子一樣有沒有
看到人家主動式的啦
AI素材的啦
都在網上噴
可是7月又覺得高鞋好棒喔
對對對
然後我不但這個
可以穩定比較低的波動之外
又有鞋可以領啊
沒錯
所以每一個時期大家可能會要審視一下
自己不要隨著市場起舞
而是都配置好的時候
就不會那麼擔心
是的
今天非常謝謝古瑜
那當然這張錶裡面
也會有配息不錯
但他的息可能從資本利得配出來的
所以他對於所謂的所得稅
稅付就不會有這麼大的壓力
那我們這邊就有做個整理
他可以去看他最近一次配息的話
到底有多少的底重來自於資本利得
那資本利得如果越高的
他基本上你要被課的稅
就會比較少一點
所以像這些有一些
到100% 90%以上的話
你領到這個洗根本就是不用擔心
就是說會有被瞌睡的一個現象
就很值得頭部朋友來做一個參考